you had such a a health scare and oh
yeah crazy story yeah I don't know how
old you were 42 when this happened when
this happened you had a heart problem
they go well you're lad or they call it
the Widowmaker your left big juicy
arteries uh is really blocked wow so
then they go we can do a simple double
bypass and I'm gonna do it in a hospital
in Northern California because they told
me the best surgeon in the world was
there I'd had a private jet going to
take me to Cedars it was in the sky
right and I canceled it so I had a
doctor who had a really bad day and he
missed the giant artery so it's like
trying to attach a fire hose to a tree
trunk and you you just hit a little
Branch instead so it didn't damage me
but it didn't fix it so then I found out
and then they they stented that one big
artery I had checked a year ago it's
wide open wow that's great thank
goodness yeah but then you had to sue
the hospital too because the guy said
looks good to me right and so that's the
part of me in retrospect should I I have
sued him because then I became the
infirm guy for years because I was naive
I'd been you know I'd done the whole the
movies at bombed the show with Louie and
Robert Smigel and Corel so I was sort of
like I'm off the radar and I go I'll be
Jimmy Stewart I I grew up with the the
you know you can't do that to me right
because what about the next guy how
could he get the wrong artery and you
said I'm going to teach them a lesson
well I just want them to be accountable
right so we so we have to go to court so
we're in San Francisco court and then we
come out my wife and I and there's all
this press there and then there's People
magazine says we'd like to put you on
the cover and I'm so I'm naive this is
97 or something I go no thank you all
right they go no we're putting you on
the cover so here's how it's settled
which I found interesting so we're going
through the trial and they blame it on
me he's got crazy Anatomy which was just
ridiculous you're wrong you're not human
just ridiculous so then there's this
this little guy with glasses at every
every day at in court so I woman from
2020 Stone film I said who's that guy
she goes that's the insurance company
for the for the doctor I go do me a
favor during the next break go up to him
and say I'm from 2020 and we'd like to
do a story about your insurance company
yeah so she comes back after the break
honest to God goes I I talked to him I
told him that oh wow five minutes later
my lawyer comes up and said they settled
follow the insurance and then their
defense was that I was doing it to get
money but I had a lot of money anyway so
we were able to you donated all the
money to charity yes heart disease and
then we built a a town in musoma in in
eastern Tanzania we built we built the
village wow that's really nice shades
orphans and stuff while you were in the
hospital with this heart problem Frank
Sinatra's in the Next Room or something
right like right there the final when I
found out the wrong artery I found out
at Cedars because I connected with PK
shot Cedars and Frank came in that night
and Frank died right and he died that
night yeah and you were there and I was
there essentially i Frank Sinatra died
in my arms wow and two weeks later the
Phil Hartman bran Hartman tragedy so I
was kind of in a zombie space at that
point
oh